morgen startet endlich das 49
euro-ticket
ich habe meinen schon vorbestellt du
auch geil endlich bezahlbarer ÖPNV zu
einem günstigen und übersichtlichen
Tarif in ganz Deutschland oder
vielleicht sollten wir nicht zu früh
jubeln schon heute gibt es heftige
Kritik am Konzept nicht nur aus der
Opposition sondern auch von
Verkehrsunternehmen und Experten die
vermuten nämlich dass durch das Ticket
genau das Gegenteil von dem passiert was
wir uns wünschen also sollten uns auf
das Ticket freuen oder wird es wirklich
unsere Öffis zerstören genau darum geht
es heute bei dr Watson
okay machen wir erstmal einen kurzen
Recap im Sommer 2022 wurde kurzfristig
das 9 euro-ticket umgesetzt die Folgen
volle Züge weniger Stau und Chaos auf
Sylt jawohl was bleibt ist der Wunsch
nach einer Anschlussregelung ab Herbst
oder spätestens ab Januar 2023 das
deutschland-ticket wird jetzt kommen
auch sehr zügig und wir haben jetzt alle
Hürden beseitigt nein ja oder eben ab
Mai na gut mit dem deutschland-ticket
kann jeder für 49 € monatlich bundesweit
den Nahverkehr nutzen wie auch beim 9
Euro Ticket yeah die Verkehrsunternehmen
sind allerdings nicht so yay für sie
waren die letzten drei Jahre echt hart
2020 sind die ticket-einnahmen im ÖPNV
über ein Viertel eingebrochen danach
sind die diese Preise explodiert und es
wird immer schwieriger Personal zu
finden 2022 kam dann im Sommer noch das
9 € Ticket mit überfüllten Zügen oben
drauf und im Winter drohte den ersten
Verkehrsunternehmen wegen der
Energiekosten
sogar die Insolvenz das war es aber noch
nicht nach Angaben vom Verband Deutscher
Verkehrsunternehmen gehen bis 2030
80.000 Beschäftigte in den Ruhestand vor
allem Menschen Ende 50 oder Anfang 60
und ohne Boomer sieht es dünn aus wenn
sie machen über die Hälfte der
Beschäftigten im ÖPNV aus besonders
drastisch ist der Mangel an Fahrern der
VDV möchte daher ehemalige Fahrer im
Ruhestand weiter beschäftigen und
Studierende als Fahrer am Wochenende und
den Spitzenzeiten einstellen außerdem
soll jetzt das 49 € Ticket
ausschließlich digital verkauft werden
als HandyTicket oder Chipkarte für viele
Kunden macht es das leichter aber gerade
im ländlichen Raum haben längst nicht
alle Verkehrsunternehmen die
Infrastruktur um digitale Tickets
auszustellen und zu lesen sagt der BDO
auch das wird teuer darum gibt's erstmal
noch Tickets mit gedruckten QR-Codes
aber nur in einer Übergangsfrist auch
die Experten mit denen wir für dieses
Video hier gesprochen haben haben uns
gesagt
die Verkehrsunternehmen sind am Limit
Personal und Energie sind gerade die
größten Kostentreiber und diese Kosten
sind längst nicht mehr für alle
Unternehmen zu stemmen okay aber was
bedeutet das jetzt für das 49
euro-ticket naja das ist etwas
komplizierter aber was feststeht ist das
ist das 9 Euro Ticket erstmal nicht mehr
geben wird aber das konnten wir
natürlich nicht so offen sitzen lassen
und haben daher einfach unser eigenes 9
Euro Ticket erschaffen das 9 € Ticket
der Wissenschaft quasi okay nicht zu
früh freuen ihr kommt damit leider nicht
nach Sylt aber dafür habt ihr einen
dauerhaften direkten Zugang zu unserer
patreon Community und das ist doch mal
mindestens genauso gut oder zumindest
unterstützt sie damit direkt dr Watson
Videos und bekommt dafür Einblicke
hinter die Kulissen ihr könnt Videos vor
allen anderen sehen und werde sogar im
Abspann der Videos genannt den KI
Kurzfilm aus dem Chat GPT Video haben
wir zum Beispiel ebenfalls schon vorab
allen pationanz gezeigt bevor hier das
ganze Video online gegangen ist das und
noch einiges mehr gibt es auf
patreon.com / dr Watson wir haben euch
natürlich den Link unten in die
Beschreibung gepackt aber macht das
bitte nur wenn ihr genug Geld übrig habt
und wenn ihr nicht monatlich zahlen
wollt wie ich das total verstehen wir
haben auch ein PayPal Konto und ein ganz
normale Spendenkonto mit einer IBAN okay
jetzt genug vom 9 € Ticket wie geht es
denn jetzt mit dem 49 Euro Ticket weiter
[Musik]
kommen wir erstmal zum Preis denn
komischerweise ist das 49 Euro Ticket
zum deutschland-ticket geworden warum
eigentlich das klingt erstens schön und
zweitens hat es den Vorteil sie können
jedes Jahr die Preise erhöhen wir nennen
das deutschland-ticket weil man den ganz
Deutschland damit fahren kann ok ob
Deutschland Ticket jetzt schön klingt
das sei mal dahingestellt aber die
Preiserhöhung wird kommen und das schon
bald die 49 € sind ein Einführungspreis
ab nächstem Jahr soll es einen
automatischen Inflationsausgleich geben
in welcher Höhe das ist noch nicht
bekannt außerdem wird das Ticket im
monatlich kündbaren Abo verkauft
verlängert sich also automatisch wenn
man nicht kündigt aber ist das nicht
trotzdem ein guter Deal selbst wenn das
Ticket nächstes Jahr dann vielleicht ein
oder zwei Euro mehr kostet für Pendler
die mit den Öffis unterwegs sind sicher
die sind heute Abo Kunden und Zahlen
ziemlich viel Geld für Monatstickets in
der jeweiligen Region als über 100 € und
natürlich werden auch die fast jährlich
mehr aber eigentlich ist das eben keine
Maßnahme die nur Pendler unterstützen
soll das Ticket soll den Umstieg vom
Auto auf Bus und Bahn fördern das
schauen uns gleich noch an und Menschen
unterstützen bei denen es finanziell
knapp ist wie sieht es also dort aus nun
für Familien bleibt es zum Beispiel
teuer nur Kinder unter sechs Jahren
können kostenfrei mitfahren
ältere Kinder und Jugendliche brauchen
ein eigenes Ticket für nochmal jeweils
49 Euro zwar haben einige
Verkehrsverbünde angekündigt dass sie
weiterhin mit Namen Optionen und
übertragbare Tickets ermöglichen wollen
aber im standardticket ist beides nicht
drin für Studis Azubis und Schüler
wollen einige Bundesländer vergünstigte
Deutschland Tickets ausgeben in anderen
wird der volle Betrag fällig Studis
sollen aber nur die Differenz zum
Semesterticket Zahlen auch für Menschen
die Bürger Geld beziehen wird es knapp
49 € sind mehr als für Mobilität
eingeplant ist 4 € Differenz mag jetzt
vielleicht nicht viel erscheinen aber
gerade wenn man trotzdem noch auf ein
Auto angewiesen ist oder ein Teil sparen
muss dann reicht das Geld dafür einfach
nicht ein bundesweites Sozialticket soll
es nicht geben aber einige Länder haben
Vergünstigungen angekündigt trotzdem
könnten Menschen mit wenig Geld noch aus
einem anderen Grund ausgeschlossen
werden einige Anbieter unter anderem die
DB wollen eine Schufa-Abfrage machen
wenn das Ticket gekauft wird um
sicherzustellen dass es auch bezahlt
werden kann richtig gehört die Schufa
deren scoring gegen EU-Recht verstößt
negativ fällt auf wer schon mal Schulden
nicht begleichen konnte aber auch wer
häufig umzieht oder mehrere Girokonten
hat könnte Abzüge bekommen und zu 8,9%
der deutschen hat die Schufa mindestens
ein Negativmerkmal gespeichert
angenommen ich kaufe mir morgen das
Ticket bei der KVB wer bekommt denn
jetzt dann meine 49 Euro naja ganz
geklärt ist das einfach noch nicht
möglich ist aber dass die Einnahmen
geteilt werden ein Teil geht an das
Verkehrsunternehmen am Wohnort des
Käufers ein Teil an das Unternehmen dass
das Ticket verkauft und der Rest wird je
nach gefahrener Kilometerzahl an die
Verkehrsbetriebe ausgezahlt das
Verhältnis dieser drei Teile ist bisher
nicht bekannt aber fest steht das kann
zu Problemen führen weil beim Ticket
deutschlandweit das gleiche drin ist
kann ich nur nach der Verpackung
entscheiden wo ich es kaufe auch wenn
ich es vor allem in Köln nutzen würde
kann ich es z.B bei der BVG holen weil
es da noch einen Gutschein für Roller
und top gibt oder ich kaufe das Ticket
bei der städtischen
Nahverkehrsgesellschaft Suhl
Zella-Mehlis warum ich das tun sollte
naja wenn ich die freie Wahl habe kann
ich mir das Ticket ja bequem per App
oder auf Deutschland ticket.de holen
keine Werbung das Ding daran ist dass
die Seite und die App nicht etwa der DB
oder dem Verkehrsministerium gehören
sondern privaten Dienstleistern die
darüber Tickets von bestimmten
Verkehrsunternehmen verkaufen wenn der
Verteilungsschlüssel für das Geld also
nicht gut ausgesteuert ist hat die
städtische Nahverkehrsgesellschaft Suhl
Zella-Mehlis nächstes Jahr volle Kassen
aber keine vorderen Busse das Geld fehlt
dann aber an anderer Stelle die
Verteilung kann also dazu führen dass
Ressourcen nicht dorthin fließen wo sie
gebraucht werden und so wird nicht ein
gutes ÖPNV-Angebot belohnt sondern eben
Kundenaktionen und Werbung
[Musik]
das deutschlandticket soll Leute zum
Umstieg auf Bus und Bahn bewegen in der
Begründung fürs Gesetz heißt es sogar
mit anderen Maßnahmen sei eine
signifikante treibhausgasminderung zu
erwarten das deutschlandticket trägt
somit wirksam zum Erreichen der
Klimaziele des Bundes im Verkehrssektor
bei ja sicher und es wird uns natürlich
auch alle zu besseren Menschen machen
und die gesamte Welt retten
aber ernsthaft damit das klappt müssten
viele vom Auto auf die Öffis umsteigen
ist das realistisch jemand der das
Monatsticket einer Stadt für 70 € nutzt
und auf 49 € Ticket umsteigt der spart
etwa 250 € im Jahr natürlich man ist
damit auch deutschlandweit flexibel aber
für viele Menschen bedeutet das gar
nichts beide Strecken im Nahverkehr
machen nicht jedem Spaß und im Alltag
ist man ja dann doch meistens eher auf
bestimmten Strecken unterwegs klar Auto
und Spritkosten auch trotzdem liegt hier
die Bequemlichkeit mehr ich glaube wer
schon ein Auto hat der wird es wohl kaum
für 250 € extra im Jahr verkaufen und
neben dem Auto noch in Deutschland
Ticket zu nutzen ist finanziell einfach
auch nicht so sinnvoll wenn man schon
den Kaufpreis Versicherungen und TÜV
Zeit dann lässt man das Auto halt auch
nicht stehen selbst wenn es insgesamt
teurer ist als mit den Öffis unterwegs
zu sein
aber wenn der ÖPNV zuverlässiger und
schneller wäre dann wäre der Umstieg
doch vielleicht eine Überlegung wert
oder
[Musik]
viele erhoffen sich vom
deutschlandticket ja auch einen besseren
Tag aber das wird leider nicht wieso oft
liegt es hier am Geld in Deutschland
sind die Länder für den ÖPNV
verantwortlich damit der finanziert
werden kann kriegen die Länder vom Bund
Geld wie viel genau das weiß allerdings
niemand auch der Bund selbst nicht wenn
man diese übersichtliche Grafik sieht
versteht man auch warum klar ist aber
der größte Teil der Finanzierung sind
die Regionalisierungsmittel die der Bund
jährlich an die Länder auszahlt 2021
waren das 9,3 Milliarden Euro die Länder
müssen aber auch in die eigene Tasche
greifen allerdings ist nicht definiert
wie hoch der Eigenanteil sein soll nach
Einschätzung des Bundesrechnungshof
zahlen die Länder auf jeden Fall nicht
genug okay die Länder wollen also mehr
Geld vom Bund der Bund mehr
Eigenbeteiligung von den Ländern der
Kompromiss für Deutschland Ticket wollen
beide sich mit je 1,5 Milliarden pro
Jahr bis 2025 daran beteiligen das Geld
soll die gestiegenen Energiekosten
Decken und die Einnahmen Rückgänge
dämpfen zusätzlich wurden die
Regionalisierungsmittel aufgestockt
klingt doch eigentlich ganz gut aber was
wenn die tatsächlichen Kosten für die
Verkehrsverbünde höher liegen als 3
Milliarden genau das befürchten Experten
und natürlich auch die Unternehmen
selbst für 2023 gibt es zwar eine
nachschussregelung die Mehrkosten können
also später noch abgerechnet werden aber
ab 2024 steht die Finanzierung damit auf
wackligen Beinen das kritisieren
Verbände stand jetzt wird das Ticket
auch unbefristet eingeführt obwohl der
Bund nur bis 2025 zahlt ab dann muss es
sich einfach magischerweise
wirtschaftlich irgendwie lohnen dass
Deutschland Ticket anzubieten aber
selbst wenn all das irgendwie
reibungslos funktionieren sollte es gibt
noch einen Knackpunkt bis hier fließt
nicht ein Cent in den Ausbau der Öffis
die Länder können die
Regionalisierungsmittel zwar so
einsetzen wie es ihnen passt oder das
Geld ist halt jetzt schon gerade knapp
mehr Fahrgäste führen nicht automatisch
zu einem weiteren Takt im Gegenteil wir
haben ja vorhin schon über das Personal
und Energie als größte Kostentreiber
gesprochen die laufenden Kosten pro
Kilometer werden also immer mehr und ob
so das Angebot aufrechterhalten werden
kann ist ungewiss okay was bedeutet das
jetzt alles wahrscheinlich wird es keine
fahrplankürzungen im großen Stil geben
dass meinen die Experten mit denen wir
gesprochen haben aber in einigen
Regionen kann es schon vorkommen dass
die Busse und Bahnen durch das
deutschland-ticket noch seltener fahren
gerade in ländlichen Regionen wo die
Anbindung schlecht ist kann das
passieren und in Regionen in denen wenig
Steuern anfallen können die Gemeinden
auch nicht einspringen wenn es
finanziell knapp wird das heißt auch
dort kann es leicht zu Kürzungen kommen
wenn die Betriebe sich nicht
refinanzieren okay das 49 Euro Ticket
hilft also einigen tatsächlich Geld zu
sparen trotzdem man muss sich sehr
bewusst für den Kauf entscheiden denn
das Geld hat man nicht durch zwei oder
drei Einzelfahrten wieder raus kaum
jemand wird sich aufgrund dessen
überzeugen lassen das Auto stehen zu
lassen dafür ist das Ticket leider zu
teuer vom Verkehrsminister heißt es dass
eine Verlängerung des neuen euro-tickets
zu teuer sein aber das Ministerium reist
wiederholt seine Klimaziele und das
wären 2018 allein im Verkehrssektor 30
Milliarden Euro in umweltschädliche
Subventionen gesteckt wurden dabei
müssen mehr Leute vom Auto auf den
öffentlichen Verkehr oder aufs Fahrrad
umsteigen das Schlimmste daran ist wir
wissen doch wie es laufen müsste das 9 €
Ticket im letzten Sommer hat für einige
Menschen nicht nur Mobilität sondern
auch gesellschaftliche Teilhabe bedeutet
und andere haben sich das Ticket geholt
obwohl sie ein Auto besitzen vielleicht
haben sie tatsächlich zum ersten Mal
seit Jahren die Öffis ausprobiert der
Kauf war für viele der Millionen Käufer
ein No-Brainer jetzt als Abo und für den
fünffachen Preis funktioniert das nicht
mehr ein Ticket ohne Ausbau der
Infrastruktur das für viele deutlich zu
teuer ist und dann auch noch teurer wird
wird wohl kaum daran anschließen können
genauso wie die Züge der Deutschen Bahn
danke euch fürs zuschauen bleibt
neugierig